hey youtubers happy 2017 there's so much
exciting stuff happening but Geoff Johns
just went on this tear announcing all
kinds of stuff like he's writing comics
again in there just happens to be a new
DC TV show they're gonna announce soon
so let's talk about what that is
starting 2017 off right there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a deceit evey related comment
on this video be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything
happy 2017 everybody it's going to be so
awesome I'll be doing like a super post
with a bunch of other stuff that's going
to be coming but what is this new DC TV
show the way Geoff Johns is talking
about it it sounds like it's definitely
live action there's only one show that I
know about that could drop this year if
he's talking about a show that's this
year now he said they're going to be
announcing something soon so that could
be something that is coming in 2018 but
he just makes it sound like this is
something that we'll be able to watch
during 2017 so that would be Black
Lightning which is coming from Greg
Berlanti who is like the master of the
CW arrowverse he was a character on The
Young Justice TV show I know we have
Young Justice season 3 coming up but I
don't think that's what geoff johns is
getting ready to announce but they did
use him in a Justice League type way on
that TV show my spells aren't working
either
we could try digging our way out
like I said playing hero started feel
pretty sweet I'm not surprised
we show real potential for this game you
ever need a mentor Virgil you just let
me know but if that's the case even
though Black Lightning has been part of
the Justice League you know they're kind
of creating TV justice league in the air
overs technically that's a Fox show so
it'd be kind of like Gotham where it's
not really connected to the other DC
shows even though it's kind of connected
is a bit weird when you're talking about
shows on other networks because people
always want them to crossover but
because it's different studios like it
was enough trouble to get Supergirl to
crossover with flash when it was still
at CBS and CBS had an ownership interest
in the CW so there was even like a
little bit of connection between them
that doesn't really exist with Fox but
because Fox has a bunch of DC shows in
its own staple now those can crossover
as much as they want to so we can talk
more about crossover stuff when they
confirm which serie it is but they're
just a number of other series that they
could be working on there's rumors of
Teen Titans birds-of-prey revival
although they have a lot of movie stuff
happening with Teen Titans characters in
the DC extended universe so I'm not
really expecting a Titan show at least
for a couple more years it's totally
possible that they could do that
whenever arrow goes off the air but I
think that has a couple seasons left in
it
I mean it is my great wish that they
would do a Titan show with characters
from the arrow burst but they also have
legends of tomorrow like the you know
they have Katie Cassidy that's going to
be doing some really weird stuff with
the Black Canary black siren character
in the next couple of years in the
arrowverse so for the time being legends
of tomorrow is sort of like their
catch-all show where they cycle cast in
and out
I'm really hoping they get to that point
with another Titans type show now they
could do like a female spin-off like
birds of prey because there are just so
many female characters that they have in
that like the last big birds of prey TV
show wasn't exactly a critical darling
and typically when they're looking for
new shows to do they look for either
characters that have never been done
before for like something that's
completely new or they look to do a
better version of characters that may
have been done a disservice in the past
so birds of prey would be like a high
candidate for that so when you look at
stuff like the big four night crossover
in the arrowverse the Hall of Justice
the Justice League things that are
happening on the flash right now just
the flash alone it just feels like
they're laying groundwork for stuff like
that to be happening in the future but
that might be a little further off than
the stuff that Geoff Johns is talking
about this isn't up for debate it's not
even a close call turn myself over to
the dominators they leave the rest of
the world alone simple no it's not
simple there doesn't matter what you've
done you can't do this
it's been an honor no all of you
to fight alongside of you now it's up to
you to keep our home safe
[Music]
berry I'm not letting you leave
no offense Oliver but you and what army
[Music]
this one
you
listen red I don't like you but when you
got a crew you don't take ahead for the
rest but if you're not familiar with the
Black Lightning character he's
originally from suicide slum in
Metropolis so there is like a bit of a
Superman connection they've changed the
way his powers have worked a little bit
over the years originally he wore a belt
that allowed him to control electrical
fields like he can create electric
blasts he can create force fields later
they reckoned that he became a metahuman
they were just born with that ability so
he didn't require any special gear to be
able to do that but he started out in
the late 1970s so he was a little bit of
a blaxploitation type character you
remember Luke Cage started out in the
early 1970s so this was sort of DC's
spin on a character like that someone
from a very Crime Alley type place
inside metropolis who decided to use his
powers to make his city his life better
they've never really explained the
fullest extent of his powers which i
think works to their benefit because
they can always surprise you with like
some big act of heroism like holy crap I
didn't know he could do that but he's
mostly been in outsiders Justice League
character the most recent retelling of
his origin story the black lightning
year one comic book basically reads a
little bit like Luke Cage so that might
be how they treat the TV show where he
comes back to suicide slum with or
without his family he has a family in
the comics they might do them on the TV
show but he comes back and tries to make
it better he left because his father was
murdered so it's like okay this is a
crap town I'm getting out of here
but then later he's inspired by the
Justice League people like Superman to
come back and make his neighborhood
better so he's a street-level hero even
though he's been part of the Justice
League so if you've seen the way the
Gotham treats you know films Gotham City
like portrays it on screen I'm expecting
the same treatment even though that's
Gotham City
and technically Black Lightning would be
going to metropolis but they haven't
confirmed that that's just where he's
from in the comics so they might be
using metropolis on that TV show but it
all just depends on which TV show Geoff
Johns is talking about whether or not
it's black lightning or something else
it's just that I would be very surprised
if there's another TV show that they
like stealth develops and are going to
drop this year it's just too hard to do
live action that way so
usually what happens is is they'll
announce the show then like a year later
they'll actually have it ready for you
to watch but in related DC TV news there
is a big change that's coming legends of
tomorrow is going to start airing on
Tuesday nights after the flash so
because that's not happening for a
couple weeks till January 24th there'll
be a couple more trailers I'll just
remind people when I post my next
legends of tomorrow video it's going to
be a bit of a schedule change but I will
be doing a 2017 video for like all the
new stuff that's coming in the next
couple of months not for the entire year
just for the next couple of months
because like Legion for instance a Fox
TV show said in the x-men universe is
going to be starting in February that a
lot of people might not know about so
that video will probably post Monday
morning just like hey you know happy new
year everybody this is what's happening
in the next couple of months but in
related comic-book news Benedict
Cumberbatch Sherlock is premiering today
episode one I'll be doing a video later
tonight so be sure to check that out
it'll be fantastic and I will say
congratulations to this week's flash
ring giveaway winner Clint Bru please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there is a new round that starts
in this video I'll just announce the
winner the next time I post a DC video
so get hype it's gonna be an awesome
2017 while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash and
you can click here for the arrow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight